what up people we're gonna watch
ourselves some benign today what
episodes is john that's two by nine
awesome that's what i like to hear yeah
guys you know the drill
mainly hit the like button that's what
you asked hit that like button full
length watch alongside patreon subscribe
click that bell thanks to the boys at
prep refraining these down
let's get to it
whoever's behind this smuggling ring
knows their way around the docks so
we're going undercover as longshoremen i
will be von tom tucker and i'm twink
tucker no
i got a job at the docks to support my
drug habit but i kept it because i love
the seagulls what are you irish now no
the leader of the cargo smoking ring
turned himself in at the 8-3 and mafia
was closing in on
case closed i guess we'll just
return these outfits great take this
back you have 10 minutes
coffee extra black extra no sugar and
real warm it gets cold on them ducks
twink tucker nah you ruined it
some nice mittens charles so i'm with
you
with your twink
perp's name is jesse hermick we arrested
him for nine counts of armed robbery but
he skipped bail he was just picked up in
newstator new york trying to pay for a
hoagie with a gun
teddy's never done anything that's
spontaneous or romantic
that's not fair
he did brew me a rose-infused pilsner
once
hi can i speak with detective teddy
wells please you can just tell him it's
cupid calling wait no that's insane tell
him it's detective peralta from the
nine-nine
after you're done here meet me in my
office i have something i need to ask
you it's food related oh mouthfeel i've
wanted to build a rapport with him since
he got here but until now all we've had
in common was our bank
guess who
[Laughter]
i have zero interest in food if it were
feasible my diet would consist entirely
of flavorless beige smoothies containing
all the nutrients required by the human
animal
so our bank got some new atms huh
tomorrow's my
anniversary with kevin i'd like to cook
him an impressive breakfast could you
help
orient me with that process i'd be
honored preparing food for once lover is
the most intimate gift of all aside from
washing their hair
what's going on diaz
are you sick do you have cholera is it
typhoid
are you a vampire my horoscope said to
wear a cowl neck today and i laughed
this is allergies no that's what killed
the dinosaurs you need to go home
oh at least let me buy you some matzo
ball
it's very soothing you know what
i'm gonna go to the deli anyway
terry loves crepe lot
that's right terry so i'm gonna go
unpack and then i'm gonna take a bath
and then we have dinner and then doing
it i was gonna say dessert oh synonym
hey amy i'll see you later okay see you
later oh
hey before i forget try to be in the
lobby in about a half an hour i got a
little surprise no
your surprises are always terrible
remember how you said that teddy would
never be so romantic as to turn a work
trip upstate into a lover's retreat to
the country oh no oh yes
he's on his way here now
uh a you're welcome
jake
i don't want to see teddy right now i'm
about to break up with him oh oh [ __ ]
why did you invite teddy up here you
poured blue soda all over my life i know
two maple teenies look at that
i have one of those maple shaped
glass bottles
look what happened with you guys i
thought you were solid didn't you just
get a joint library card don't remind me
i'm gonna be untangling that web for a
month
this is fine all right i'll figure it
out i'm just gonna call teddy tell him
to turn around and go home no he's a
really good detective he'll figure out
something's wrong
i made a reservation next thursday at a
well-lit korean restaurant in midtown
it's the least romantic place i could
think of scully's bathroom would go on
all right look this is totally my fault
so i promise i'll do everything i can to
help tonight i will focus solely on you
and teddy
and my very naked girlfriend
wow sophia does not care about the cloud
at all
oh golly
just let me help you i'll get you perp
to talk i can be very persuasive
i just negotiated my baby girls down
from a pony to a hamster
little fools
i am not sick gina where is the cold
medicine i hate to point out the option
why do you need the meds if you're not
sick huh
to fight off the cold symptoms that my
healthy body is exhibiting
why
oh god is it that lean
okay if diaz won't accept our help we
got to go behind her back we definitely
should go behind her back that's the
opposite side of where the germs are
coming from
man i oh
[Laughter]
hey look the dolls are gross but i think
once we bury them this place could be
kind of romantic
yep
totally
but you know what would be even more
romantic is hanging out fully clothed
with two other people who have fallen
out of love
thank you for being understanding yeah
well for the record very cool girlfriend
the coolest hey and teddy doesn't get
here for another 30 minutes till then
what's miguel great plan
in the closet where they can't watch us
yep no there got to be more in there
yeah
step in learning how to cook is learning
how to taste so close your eyes
and open your mouth this isn't burning
man boyle
tell me what i'm eating fine it's a
shark vermont cabot
now describe what you taste
cheese
my favorite meal is a simple roast
chicken and potatoes it was the only
dish my mother knew how to cook and when
i eat it i feel as though i am once
again inside her womb oh my i want a
sandwich i make a sandwich i eat
the sandwich
marge i'd like to be alone with the
sandwich
yikes where's teddy he's in the shower i
said hi to him we chatted for like a
minute and i almost blew it oh i'm sure
you're overstating that he said he was
really looking forward to a romantic
evening and i panicked and yelled lol
oh
the four of us will dine together and
keep things super unromantic i'm great
at that yeah he is
all right so after dinner pretend you're
sick and say you want to go straight to
bed me and you have to pick up the perps
super early in the morning so you only
have to act normal around teddy from the
elevator to the room do you think you
can do that yes yes say yes i can do it
i can be normal yes i can do it
i can be normal
hey everybody
there he is teddy in the heart
oh yeah
[Laughter]
our place is really nice it's got a
fireplace i want to snuggle up next to
that thing with you no i don't want to
do that
cancer
sitting by fire is actually worse than
sucking on a tailpipe of a bus
because of the germs fumes
[Laughter]
great back and forth
oh i never need a drink menu i got the
thrills for the pills
cause i'm a pilsner man oh i haven't
heard
i want to break it up
us i want to break us up
hey folks
everyone excited to be here we having a
good time
we are not
we have to act soon that cold medicine
bs chugged it was the non-drowsy kind
she's all over the place hey hey
huh
whoa why didn't someone answer that
thought
get it i would get it
hello no there's no michael here you
have the wrong number goodbye
i'm michael
you should be proud of it because you
are the greatest detective i've ever
known
she's so hopped up on that stuff her
brain's gonna blow i'm gonna interrogate
[Laughter]
so
them
go ahead
and pour your eggs right into the pan
nice and slow
[Laughter]
we hear that sizzle that means the heat
is a little too high on those eggs well
the the higher the heat the faster the
eggs cook the sooner kevin eats am i
incorrect
cooking is about patience
are you completely insane
the hand the hand is the middle man okay
what you did is the culinary equivalent
of
unprotected sex
yeah
i only wish in return i could get back
all the time i just wasted on this
futile project
i'm just gonna make kevin plain toast
for breakfast oh
that is low order him a pizza the main
reason you want to break up with me is
the pilsners
i i like other drinks
it's delicious i want more
can i maybe just have two hours alone
with my laptop so i can type up a draft
great idea in the meantime we can just
chat you know what
we should go no actually i think you
should stay
so we can all talk about the real reason
there's a problem in my relationship
with amy which is you jake
[Music]
whoa about how you told her that you
liked her before you went undercover
oh oh
i did but that was many moons ago was it
because i know for a fact you also told
her when you got back and every time you
would she would get confused and then
our relationship would get out of sync
amy liked you back
did you
maybe
yes
a little oh god guys that's all the time
jesus
go upstairs and rip the heads off some
dolls good night i'm gonna leave too
if you'd please leave my toothbrush and
my home brewing kit at the doorstep i'll
pick them up tomorrow i guess that's the
last time i invite teddy on a trip right
drama
i'm gonna go yeah me too
[Music]
oh
who's gonna eat all that food you should
have seen the look on your face when you
found out amy liked you yeah listen to
me
like like i'm an adult all this who
likes whose stuff sounds very high
school i know it's stupid you're totally
right i'm an adult come on
thank you
puppets around the bed
it's warm it's a croque monsieur kevin
and i shared one on a rainy afternoon in
paris on our first anniversary
it's one of our most treasured memories
i'm sure it's not up to your standards
but
kevin seemed to enjoy it
thank you
for your guidance
oh
gross huh
no
it's perfect
he's a natural chef
now i know how salieri felt
she talks in her sleep
i'm gonna rip your head off
i'm gonna rip your damn head off grandma
oh terra bear what if she sleeps forever
oh
you literally have been in a coma since
yesterday now i know you like to act
like you don't need any help but we all
do
i ask five dudes to spot me when i'm
doing my squats
i want to see that cutaway now's the
time where you say thank you for all
your help thank you for all your help
wait is that a smile i see
possibly
my immune system is too weak to fight
off my smile muscles
[Laughter]
so how'd it go with sofia
good we made up we're still together
i told her you know everything was being
used in the past and we're just friends
i mean don't get me wrong i am thrilled
to know that you used to like me and i
will bring it up constantly
great
hey should we make a left up here at you
used to like this guy's asleep
i could always just cut across it amy
used to like jake boulevard okay stop it
or i'll crash the car don't do that
not a doctor shh
jeez
oh jesus
hey what are you gonna do
it's really funny it's pretty funny
i think i think jake's still in the amy
what oh
that's gonna spell drama down the line
in a couple of episodes when they're
you know when eva longoria's uh guest
appearances run out i like eva longoria
yeah uh she's not funny
[Laughter]
she's she's her she's they write her
they write her comment i can feel like
the writing of the comedy yeah everyone
else is pretty natural
and her i'm like
you feel you're doing the sitcom beats
yeah yeah you're written to be cool
sitcom girlfriend with spunk yeah yeah
yeah but i still like her i still like
her i think her energy is still really
good in those scenes and like she plays
off of everybody really well yeah even
if i can feel some of the writing more
so than the spontaneity of like the cast
who's always been doing this together
man i didn't mind it or i thought she
was great in the first episode she had
no none of that was ever distracting to
me but
here for some reason it really stood out
it might just be my
awareness that it's eva longoria yeah
and i mean draws attention yeah and i
mean you know i associate her with
less with sitcoms so you know it feels
more like oh you know you're stepping
into a new lane for my viewing
experience and what else have you seen
her in well i associate her with like
desperate housewives which is like
there's humor in there what else
what else come on
come on other than desperate house yeah
no i'm like i haven't seen like a heck
ton of her work
one more one more
evil or yeah no that's uh eva mendes
racist
i know there's something and if i can
name enough movies that even mendes is
in eventually i'll get to an evil
longuria movie i don't know i i i would
just say that i have no idea what else
she's been doing it's okay
it's okay i didn't have any [ __ ] for
that one
i'll come back next next appearance i'm
gonna have her full imdb memorized
uh but you know this is this was really
funny this was hilarious i loved all the
story lines yeah i did too you could
have learned something from the rosa
story line i absolutely could have
learned something about hey
go home just take the day
it'll be better fine it's just allergies
greg
it'll be fine
i'll stay in denial so that we never
have to stop
yeah i was flashing back to a week ago
yeah like rosa no don't don't make the
same mistakes i made i was like man if
they all started getting sick this is
gonna be
an ironic episode you're watching right
now
we do get a lot of funny little uh
cosmic timings with these shows that we
watch
very true that was uh yeah i thought we
got to see the most diversity with uh
stephanie beatrice that she's haven't
got a showcase in this before because um
yeah the physical bit of when she's on
the hopped up meds yeah like the way she
plays with like the fast-paced rhythm
that's chipmunk squirrel attitude yeah
i love that i'm proud of you
it's a disgusting name
it's yours you're
that's hysterical that's [ __ ]
hilarious this had a couple moments like
that that like caught me off guard and
then bolstered by all the different whip
uh like snap zooms to emphasize the
dolls later on but like that moment the
moment at the table
when uh the whole when teddy actually
confronts jake like both of those were
moments where i was like caught by the
moment and like it was teddy man what i
told you he's the worst [ __ ] teddy he's
the worst yeah
poor teddy but
not really i guess
i mean yeah i guess not really
especially if like uh the partner at
work saying he likes her and she's
getting confused i mean yeah i would be
i'd be pretty flustered
by that yeah
i can't say i blame teddy for being
upset and i appreciate i like it doesn't
happen every episode or even every few
episodes but when they bother to have a
moment like that that really hits like a
oh
oh this is like an interpersonal drama
right here yeah you know like i i
appreciate the way they use those
moments because they're quite striking
and then uh and then yeah we can bury
that lie just a little longer but he's
evil and gory's right up there and he
could be banging her i know and then
teddy's ruining that i know what a dick
friggin teddy boy what a dick it seems
like they still got to to you know
resume their nice night i know and
that's why i'm assuming my thought first
went
it's like but
but he gets to bang evil hungary
what are you doing teddy come on man
it's not bro code bro i mean him eva
longoria and and melissa famero they
have similar
features yeah the person's gotta type it
does
uh but yeah i mean that was a funny-ass
scene and
awkward as hell tense everything would
boil and
um
there is an art to the scrambled eggs i
mean it's funny because that's what
olivia and i argue about because
olivia's very much like just get it done
get it done
and i'm like no you gotta cook the eggs
slowly and then then you gotta turn it
off right before they're done because
the pan will still continue to cook it a
little bit when the pan's off and you'll
get it right at the perfect sweet spot
yeah it'll be just a little fluffy but
they won't be wet at all yeah it'll be
perfect
and she's just like just blessed to do
100 and throw it in there yeah the fast
food cookies just like scraps
scrambled eggs scared i was just like
all right and
papers right there's little sheets of
egg yeah
um
yeah sorry i relate with that i never
thought about that
the emotional association with food um
that regard
well because it's easy to take for
granted because you eat you know so many
times in your life but then again yeah
like big moments are often tied to
special food
sure we used to get vitello's pizza yeah
and i used to cook us breakfast for
weight more than two people 30 pancakes
pancake john double batch wait an hour
and a half for joe to make those
pancakes
make it an obnoxious amount that's right
man he wants them to take home nothing
it's a lot of pancakes you know what's
funny to me about this episode is that
there was a moment that stood out to me
actually as a contradiction of the
brooklyn of the immaculately consistent
brooklyn nine-nine canon which is
i distinctly recall in a previous
episode captain holt saying that he read
charles's pizza blog partly because it
was the only one that measured mouth
feel so then to come back to this
episode and to find that he cares not
for food in the slightest i i was a
little taken aback by yeah i was like
what it doesn't completely undo it but
it does raise an eyebrow yeah cause then
you're like why would you serve kevin
plain toast when you at least seem to
care about pizza
it seemed a little bit out of carrot it
was weird it seems like there'd be two
you can see both versions of hold one
who only eats for
necessity
like nutrient requirement
and the other that is
very much about the taste yeah the
experience yeah so
um you can see both versions but i would
have definitely likened him more to the
one who's about taste and experience
especially based
off something like that what you were
saying yeah
and i mean he's not exactly a skinny guy
well so many yeah that's true yeah and i
mean so many of the jokes with holt are
about him being deadpan but super
sophisticated yeah yeah i would like it
would stand to reason that he would
probably care a little bit about food oh
[ __ ] john you just poked a hole in the
bear
no more fun it's not a good storyline
any longer
but i love i i did love getting the two
of them together and i and i
i appreciate i feel like that egg
conversation is so universal in any
like conversation about cooking that
gets far enough is like you know that
difference of like no no no no it's not
the same scrambled egg experience it's
not it's not if it cooks faster they
taste different they're harder and
they're yeah they're more burnt and
they're more like yeah the consistency
is all different i mean there's all
kinds of ways to cook your scrambled
eggs it's like if you get it like just
hot enough
and then you pour it in
good or then
you know if you are looking to do it
fast you could you could do is really
heat it up wait till it's really hot the
oil then just throw it in there should
get it done right away it's not like
denny's does it
taste it in denny's you're just like get
it over with really got a lot of eggs
we can't afford to heat the grill up
every time we're just leaving this thing
on all day
we have a one temperature cooks all
policy on this yeah top grill yeah
so
yeah so yeah man that's true that's very
true
anyway good though thank you guys so
much for being here this was a fun
episode as always
ah
brooklyn nine-nine
best in the biz
keep on watching along
hit that patreon like and subscribe and
click the notification bell
and uh hey yeah i thought we were done
what's going on here should we shout out
some pictures
we should just end the video
mouth feel
[Music]